a week after his tragic death the family
of renick lambie is fighting for justice
the 61 year old was hit and killed last
thursday as he was riding his motorized
wheelchair home in the northeast valley
i spoke exclusively with his wife and
son in a story you'll only see here on 8
news now
he was a caring man a giving man
a man with dreams that he lived every
day
memories of a life full of love blend
with
sadness over time stolen too soon
i wish i was there
to help him to be aided
to him so he don't die rennick lambie's
wife
and son share what they'll miss most
about him
a week after he was hit and killed by a
car here
near lake mead and lamb while riding
home in his motorized wheelchair
no one wants to go home and have to tell
their children
that their grandfather isn't here
anymore police
are still searching for the driver who
they say
took off after the crash the lambies
have their own mission to find this
person
and hold them accountable there's no way
you can sleep at night
knowing that you hit somebody left them
there to die
and did not come forward that's why
they're asking us
all to take a moment and think of renek
the days he spent as a father husband
grandfather
and friend even when the skies
that we look upon
should crumble and fall and remember the
justice
he now so desperately deserves
i am asking from my heart
please come forward please say something
renick was hit on abel's lane near lake
mead and lamb again in the northeast
valley
if you know anything please call police
or crime stoppers
the lambies are also raising money to
hire a private investigator
if you'd like to help head to our
website eight newsnow dot com